What does job security really mean?
It means financial stability.
Waking up and knowing "I can provide
for myself and my family."
A freelance career can 100 percent
provide that if you build it wisely.
As counterintuitive as it may seem,
freelancing may be the best way
to build long-term stability.
[The Way We Work]
Five out of 10 American
workers watching this
will have a freelance career by 2025.
That's just two or three years out.
Some of us will perform tasks like making
deliveries or doing remote data entry,
and some of us will be writers,
graphic designers, product specialists,
marketeers, software engineers,
data analysts or business consultants
who are paid per project
and not tied to any one company.
Having a freelance career
gives you the power
to get your true market value
and the flexibility to build life
the way you want it.
But most importantly, it gives you
control over your future,
making you less reliant
on a single employer.
Hiring freelancers is good
for organizations, too.
When freelancers come on board,
they come with knowledge
from multiple employers.
Freelancers also tend to be more
up-to-date on their skills.
They constantly read, listen and learn
new approaches to remain employable,
and freelancers offer a jolt of energy.
They arrive ready to hit
the ground running.
So how can you be part
of this freelance future?
Here are some steps.
Step one: Identify your core value.
Talk to people in your network
of current and former employers
and ask them what qualities
make you someone who's worth hiring?
Are you thorough or fast?
Are you strategic?
What types of projects
do you really excel at?
Figure out exactly what value
you bring as a freelancer.
Step two: Communicate it to employers.
Once you know your value,
you're in great place
to approach potential employers,
whether it's places
you've worked with in the past
or other businesses
in the same industry and say,
"This is what I will do for you
and this is the impact
it could have on your business."
Make your value clear
on your LinkedIn profile
and on your personal website
and ask to be paid what you're worth,
which means you should do
some research on pricing
and your value should
translate into your fees.
Step three: Nurture early relationships.
In the beginning,
it's often in your best interest
to take whatever jobs you're offered.
It's not all going to be great or easy,
but you will learn so much.
You'll start to see that you're better
working with mission-driven companies
or with managers
who don't beat around the bush.
Or whether you're happier working remotely
or going into an office
working with peers.
Every time you finish
working with a new client,
ask them for feedback.
Find out what worked well.
What can I do better?
As a freelancer, you need to be proactive
and find ways to improve.
It will not only make you better,
but help raise your value
in the marketplace.
Step four: Grow your client
base over time.
As a freelancer,
your existing customers
are your best references.
When a project is about to end,
ask whether they know others
who might benefit from your services
or ask if they can promote you
and your work in their internal channels,
social media platforms or email groups.
Don't be discouraged.
It takes time and consistency
to build a stable of clients.
Put your focus on building
a reputation for good work
and you'll eventually have to turn down
more jobs than you can accept.
Step five: Join a freelance community.
Whatever type of freelancer you are,
find ways to connect
with others in your field.
What are the LinkedIn
or Facebook groups to join?
Which events to go to
and which podcasts to listen to?
This community will not only help you
learn and give you leads on work,
but it will also contain peers
that you can vent to when you need it.
If you're interested in freelancing,
don't wait until you get fired
or laid off to make that leap.
Remember, when you rely on one employer,
they own your future.
But by building
your freelance capabilities,
you'll have the power to decide
not only who you want to work with,
but when and in what capacity.
And when downturns come,
you'll be better able to withstand them
with a network of people
who are excited to work with you.